Der Weg zum Erfolg
ist eigentlich ein einsamer Weg.
Am Anfang des Weges hat man
sehr viele Kollegen und Freunde.
Wenn man weiter und weiter kommt
und weiter macht,
dann verabschieden sich viele Leute.
- Warum?
Teils aus Neid, teils, weil sie
vielleicht andere Interessen haben.
Oder sie wollen
nur normale Angestellte sein.
Das könnte ich nie sein.
Ich muss etwas machen.
Dann ist man eigentlich ...
Am Schluss steht man nur
mit der Familie da.
Aber man braucht
sonst auch niemanden.
Die Familie ist das Wichtigste.
Es ist das erste Mal,
dass ich hier oben bin.
* Drollige Trompeten-
und Tubaklänge *
Enver Fazliji will reich werden.
Dem ordnet er nicht alles,
aber vieles unter.
Er eilt von Termin zu Termin,
von Geschäft zu Geschäft,
von Erfolg zu Erfolg.
Neuerdings kauft er Grundstücke
und treibt die Planung eines Projek-
tes bis zur Baugenehmigung voran.
Dann verkauft er alles
an einen Generalunternehmer -
selbstverständlich mit gutem Gewinn.
Sieht es bis jetzt gut aus?
- Ja, es sieht richtig gut aus.
Das ist schon Fels, oder?
Wir befinden uns in der Ostschweiz,
an der Grenze zu Liechtenstein.
Hier sollen
vier Terrassenhäuser entstehen.
Geplanter Verkaufspreis:
knapp 900'000 Fr. pro Wohneinheit -
Aussicht inklusive.
Herr Steiger hat das Haus
des Nachbarn renoviert.
So haben wir uns kennengelernt.
Als ich
mit dem Nachbarn verhandelte,
trafen wir uns auf der Gemeinde.
Er vertrat die Gegenpartei.
Zuerst war er mir
sehr unsympathisch.
Dann habe ich gemerkt,
dass er eigentlich sehr lieb ist.
Das ist so.
Heute ist Herr Steiger
sein Architekt.
Denn mit Geld bewegt man nicht
nur Dinge, sondern auch Menschen.
Das gilt freilich auch für Nachbarn,
die Einsprachen erheben -
oder es auch lassen können.
Wir haben für die Nachbarn
den ganzen Wald gelichtet.
Niemand hat sich natürlich
daran beteiligt.
Die Idee kam von Herrn Steiger.
So hat man am Abend länger Sonne.
Wenn die Sonne hinter dem Wald ist,
scheint immer noch die Sonne.
Jetzt haben alle davon profitiert.
Auch von der Strasse
und der Kanalisation.
Ist es ein Geben und Nehmen
im Baugeschäft?
Mehr ein Geben, wenn ich es
von meiner Seite aus betrachte.
Wobei Geben
ja seliger denn Nehmen sein soll.
Kommt hinzu, dass das letzte Hemd
sowieso keine Taschen hat.
Wer wüsste das besser
als Enver Fazliji?
Vor fünf Jahren
traf ich ihn zum ersten Mal.
Er sei selbständig, seit er 19 sei,
sagte er.
Damals starb seine Grossmutter
und die Familie suchte vergeblich
nach einem muslimischen Bestatter.
Vermutlich hätten andere
das gleiche Problem, dachte er sich
und sagte seinem Vater, er gründe
eine Firma und stelle ihn an.
Zwei Onkel und ein Cousin
des Verstorbenen sind gekommen.
Die Eltern und die Geschwister sind
bereits nach Kosovo vorausgeflogen.
Die Zeit drängt:
Vom Tod bis zur Beisetzung
sollten im Islam
nicht mehr als 48 Std. vergehen.
* Sanfte Gitarrenklänge *
Der Tote wird gründlich gewaschen.
Wer die Ewigkeit im Paradies
verbringen will,
der sollte rein vor Allah treten,
erklärt mir Fazliji.
Am Anfang war es schon schwer.
Die drei, vier ersten Aufträge
waren schon belastend und haben mich
auch im Schlaf verfolgt.
Haben Sie schlecht geträumt?
- Ja, zum Beispiel.
Der Fehler war, das ich es
mit nach Hause genommen habe.
Man muss Berufliches und Privates
klar trennen.
Je mehr man das macht,
umso besser kann man damit umgehen.
Aber es belastet einen
trotzdem jedes Mal.
Man denkt immer: "Eigentlich
könnte es mich morgen treffen
oder jemanden aus der Familie."
Haben Sie Angst, dass es jemanden
aus der Familie treffen könnte?
Ja, das beschäftigt mich.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie ich damit umgehen würde.
Würden Sie Ihren Vater waschen,
wenn er sterben würde?
Ja, wenn er das möchte,
dann mache ich das.
Das ist für mich selbstverständlich,
dass ich das mache.
* Gebetsgesang *
Ein Regisseur
wurde auf Fazliji aufmerksam
und engagierte ihn spontan für einen
Kurzspielfilm namens "Facing Mecca".
Er spielt einen muslimischen
Bestatter, also sich selbst.
Die Geschichte dreht sich
um einen syrischen Flüchtling,
dessen Frau stirbt.
Weil die Gemeinde kein muslimisches
Grabfeld zur Verfügung stellen will,
findet sie ihre letzte Ruhe -
mit Fazlijis Hilfe - in einem Wald.
Ist es gut?
- Super.
Hier winkt kein Geld,
allenfalls Ruhm.
Der Weg dorthin ist jedoch steinig.
Schau ihn einfach an.
Einfach anschauen.
- Ganz trocken.
Und dann gehst du da rüber.
Ich werde es auch nicht vergessen.
- Ja, ich auch nicht.
Okay?
- Ja.
Set and action!
Ich glaube,
mich braucht es nicht mehr.
Ich werde mich
an dieser Stelle verabschieden.
Das vergesse ich nie.
- Ich auch nicht.
Noch einmal!
Versuch es mehr als Gag zu spielen.
Es ist ein kleiner smarter Gag,
den du noch bringst.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
So wie du bist, wie du es immer
sagst, wenn du eine Witz machst.
And action!
Das vergesse ich nie.
- Ja, ich auch nicht.
Cut! Noch einmal.
Wir spielen es wieder durch.
Ja, ich kann es langsam auswendig.
Ja, hoffentlich.
Das ist ein Gag. Dann kannst du noch
einen Moment bei ihm bleiben.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Man muss vieles beachten.
And action!
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Cut! Noch einmal.
Ich auch nicht, glaub es mir.
Genauso kannst du es sagen.
Ich auch nicht, glaub mir das.
- Soll ich sagen: "glaub mir das"?
Nicht "Glaub mir das." Aber so.
- Ich auch nicht.
Ich auch nicht. Das ist so.
Ich glaube,
mich braucht es nicht mehr.
Ich werde mich
an dieser Stelle verabschieden.
Das vergesse ich nie.
- Ich auch nicht.
You're welcome.
Jetzt wird kurz umgebaut.
Sie müssen das Dings verschieben.
Doch, es ist ...
... halt ein neues Berufsfeld.
Vielleicht eines für die Zukunft?
Weniger. Ich habe gemerkt,
dass es im Film immer gut aussieht.
Aber in den letzten zwei Tagen,
in denen wir gedreht haben ...
Es ist schon viel Arbeit.
Peter, hast du gespürt,
dass ich mein Bestes gab? - Ja.
Ja, ich ging fast in die Knie.
Hast du geschlottert?
- Ja, ja.
Wenn Ihr Leben ein Film wäre,
was hätte er für einen Titel?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich würde sagen ...
Weil ich immer gerne alles mache
und ausprobiere vielleicht:
"Der Macher".
Einfach weil ich alles gerne mache
und ausprobiere.
"Der Macher"
kommt mir spontan in den Sinn.
Sorry, we have to shoot,
we're losing the light.
Wieso nur
diese permanente Betriebsamkeit?
Mit dieser Frage reisten wir
vor fünf Jahren ins Presevo-Tal,
eine albanische Enklave
auf serbischem Gebiet,
nahe der kosovarischen Grenze.
Das ist die Heimat seiner Eltern.
Hier verbrachte Faziliji
seine ersten sechs Lebensjahre.
Dann holte sein Vater, der als Sai-
sonnier in die Schweiz gegangen war,
ihn und seine zwei Brüder nach.
Das Leben sollte ihnen
eine Chance geben.
Darauf warten
seine Onkel und Cousins immer noch.
In den Wintermonaten liegt die
Arbeitslosigkeit hier nahe bei 100 %.
Die Zeit steht still -
bis in den nächsten Sommerferien
die Verwandten
aus dem Ausland zu Besuch kommen.
Man gehört eben doch nicht
zu 100 % zu ihnen.
Man ist ja nicht hier, man leidet
ja nicht mit bei der Armut,
die die Leute hier haben,
oder bei der Perspektivlosigkeit.
Fazliji
machte eine Lehre als Sachbearbeiter
und baute nebenbei
ein Bestattungsunternehmen auf.
Er arbeitet und arbeitet -
als ob ihm die Armut
dicht auf den Fersen bliebe.
Ihr Ziel ist schon,
einmal Millionär zu werden, oder?
Millionär nicht,
aber das ich mir keine Sorgen
ums Geld machen muss.
Und das ich irgendwann
in einem anderen Land leben kann,
in dem man nicht so viel Stress
ausgesetzt ist
oder so viele Sorgen hat.
Wo würden Sie dann hingehen?
Z.B. hierher.
Zurück hierher?
- Zum Beispiel.
Würde es Ihnen hier nicht langweilig?
Lieber langweilig
als zu viel Stress.
Sie würden ja nicht mehr
richtig dazugehören, oder?
Sie wären immer der Schweizer.
- Das müsste man ausprobieren.
Hier ist die Jugend ... Ich habe
noch oft mit Jugendlichen zu tun.
Hier ist die Jugend
noch nicht so ...
... kaputt wie in der Schweiz,
würde ich sagen.
Ausgang und so kennen sie nicht.
Es sind
alle in bescheidenen Verhältnissen.
Ist aus Ihrer Sicht
die Jugend in der Schweiz kaputt?
Aus meiner Sicht ja.
Sie gehen jedes Wochenende
in den Ausgang - Alkohol, Drogen.
Sie hören nicht mehr auf die Eltern.
Das kann es auch nicht sein.
Sie haben den Respekt vor den
Eltern, den alten Leuten verloren.
Idealisieren Sie
das Leben hier nicht ein wenig?
Das könnte sein, ja das könnte sein.
Und wenn Sie zurückgingen,
kämen Sie auf die Welt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich so.
Aber ich sage nur,
es ist eine Möglichkeit.
Ich habe immer noch die Option,
zurück in mein Heimatland zu gehen.
Das Haus, in dem er
seine ersten Jahre verbrachte,
steht seit Langem leer.
Inzwischen wohnt er
mit seinen Eltern und Brüdern
in einem Mehrfamilienhaus
im Kanton Solothurn -
alles finanziert von Enver Fazliji.
Entweder war hier das Wohnzimmer ...
Hier hat man
einfach am Boden so ... äh ...
... Schaumstoffkissen gehabt.
Hier sass man.
Ein Teppich war auch noch da.
Hier in diesem Zimmer
bin ich auf die Welt gekommen.
Die Hebamme war die Grossmutter.
Seither
ging es für ihn stetig aufwärts.
Alles eine Frage des Willens,
sagt er.
Waren Sie nie "der Jugo"?
Am Anfang als ich klein war schon,
aber ich habe gemerkt,
dass die Leute ganz anders auf einen
reagieren, je mehr Erfolg man hat.
Desto lieber sind sie
mit einem zusammen
oder desto lieber werden sie mit
einem gesehen oder reden mit einem.
Man wird ganz anders behandelt,
als wenn man arm ist.
Oder keine Schulbildung hat.
Also man integriert sich eigentlich
über Erfolg?
Das ist so.
Also in meinem Fall ist das so.
Man kann sich in der Schweiz
nur über Erfolg integrieren.
Nur muss man eben risikofreudig sein
oder einfach etwas riskieren,
denn wenn man nichts riskiert,
hat man auch nichts davon.
Letztendlich investiert man ja
auch sehr viel Zeit.
Man vernachlässigt die Familie
und, und, und.
Man will ja,
dass es zum Erfolg kommt.
Und wer erfolgreich ist, der kann
immer noch erfolgreicher werden.
Neben seinen Immobiliengeschäften ist
er weiter als Bestatter unterwegs -
in diesem Falle Richtung Zagreb.
Hallo, Mustafa!
Gut, ich bin in Kroatien.
Weisst du, von wo sie sind
oder wo sie in der Schweiz sind?
Ah, Buchs, Aargau.
Okay, gut!
Ja, ich ...
Okay, ich rufe sie gleich an.
Danke, tschüss!
Die Toten schlafen zwar,
der Tod hingegen nicht.
Gestorben wird immer.
Eine krisensichere Branche also.
Aber auch ein hart umkämpfter Markt.
Hat sich das verändert,
was die Leute bereit sind,
für ihre Toten auszugeben?
Ich bin nun seit zwölf Jahren
in diesem Geschäft,
habe ein Bestattungsinstitut.
In den letzten Jahren
hat es sich spürbar verändert.
Die Leute sind weniger bereit,
für ihre Angehörigen,
in den meisten Fällen ihre Eltern,
Geld auszugeben.
Sie geben lieber mehr Geld für
ihre Haustiere oder ihre Autos aus.
Aber wenn jemand von den Eltern
verstorben ist,
dann soll es so günstig
und so schnell wie möglich gehen.
Der Direktor der Sargfabrik
und seine rechte Hand
zeigen Fazliji ihre Produktion.
Hier entstehen jedes Jahr
65'000 Särge -
in allen möglichen Variationen.
Das ist nun
das amerikanische Modell.
Fazliji möchte seine Produkte-Palette
mit Importen aus Kroatien erweitern:
Er will schon bald eine Art
Prix-Garantie-Bestattung anbieten.
Wir können die Särge nur von Italien
kaufen. Sie sind aber viel teurer.
Die Leute sind nicht mehr bereit,
das zu bezahlen.
Deswegen Italien oder jetzt
die Möglichkeit in Kroatien.
Darum bin ich auch hier.
Ich brauche nur solche
für Auslandüberführungen.
Es wir noch alles
altmodisch von Hand gemacht.
Hier wird getestet, ob er dicht ist.
Wenn ein Verstorbener im Sarg liegt,
kommt es ab und zu vor,
dass er Flüssigkeit absondert.
Darum braucht man auch
einen Zinksarg.
Es ist eine interessante Methode.
Fazliji muss weiter -
weiter zum nächsten Erfolg.
Der Film "Facing Mecca" feiert
im Zürcher Kino Riff Raff Premiere.
Geht's gut? Du siehst sexy aus.
Ich habe mich für dich
hübsch gemacht.
Schön, dich wieder einmal zu sehen.
Fazliji hat seine KV-Lehrmeisterin
samt Anhang eingeladen -
und seine Frau.
Er hat sich Zeit genommen
für eine Hochzeit -
mit Adelina aus seinem Heimatdorf.
Du konntest
gute Schauspieler organisieren.
Natürlich ...
Den besten Amateurschauspieler
hast du ...
Den hatte ich auch dabei, ja.
- Also Amateur ...
Mit dem Cast bin ich mega zufrieden.
Das hast du gut gemacht.
Der Film kommt sicher gut an.
Und auch wenn das nicht so ist,
sagen trotzdem alle er sei gut.
Es traut sich niemand zu sagen,
er sei schlecht.
Aber man spürt es,
wenn er nicht ankommt.
Ich muss schauen, wohin wir müssen.
Ich glaube, da vorne.
Eigentlich sollte ich
auf diesem Plakat sein.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum nicht.
Das muss ein Fehler sein.
* Loungemusik *
Das vergesse ich nie.
- Ich auch nicht.
* Applaus *
Der Film kommt nicht nur
bei der Premiere gut an,
sondern gewinnt später
einen Preis nach dem anderen
an internationalen Festivals
und verpasst den Oscar
nur um Haaresbreite.
Eine neue Erfahrung für Fazliji:
Lohn in Form von Applaus.
Enver habe ich sehr kurzfristig
vor dem Dreh getroffen.
Wir haben im Bahnhofcafe
ein Casting gemacht.
Das war mein erstes Casting
überhaupt.
Der Film beruht
auf einer wahren Geschichte,
einer wahren Begebenheit.
Wir haben das sehr eng recherchiert.
Erst im Nachhinein
haben wir herausgefunden,
dass Enver
den echten Fall begleitet hat.
Das war für uns beide ein Schock
und auch ein Glücksmoment gewesen.
Ja, aber ich habe sie
nicht im Wald begraben.
Beim Apero erzählt er, er habe
die Tote damals ausfliegen lassen:
via Damaskus in heimische Erde.
Auch das ein voller Erfolg - einer,
bei dem er gerne draufgelegt habe.
Gehen wir rauf?
- Ja.
Ah, guten Morgen!
Heute verkauft er
mehrere Immobilienprojekte
an eine Investorengruppe.
Es gehe um viel Geld,
um sehr viel Geld.
Heute werden wir den Vertrag, das
Verpflichtungsgeschäft beurkunden.
Wir nennen hier keine Preise.
Sonst musst du hinaus.
Du hörst ja alles.
Diese Unterschrift macht
aus dem Macher einen gemachten Mann.
Gut, das wäre dann alles.
Ich gratuliere euch zum Geschäft.
Alles Gute und viel Erfolg.
Dir auch.
Darauf hat er hingearbeitet - endlich
das grosse Geld - mit 32 Millionär.
Man weiss, man hat es abgeschlossen.
Man ist froh, dass es
erfolgreich abgeschlossen wurde.
Aber ich habe es eigentlich ...
... besser erwartet.
Ich stelle mir immer vor:
Wenn ich das schaffe, dann ...
... dann werden ich einen
riesigen Freudensprung machen.
Aber es ist nicht so.
Die Binsenweisheit stimmt also:
Geld alleine macht nicht glücklich.
Aber es macht offenbar Appetit:
Appetit auf mehr.
Wieso nur ein Porsche, wenn man auch
noch einen zweiten haben könnte?